Let's talk about Whitespace for a moment.
You may have noticed, when I was entering text in the editor before,
that even though I put text on multiple lines--
when I rendered it in HTML,
it rendered all on a single line.
This is because, in HTML, all Whitespace--
new lines, tabs, spaces--
all turn into a single space.
To force our HTML to have multiple lines,
we can use another tag called the "br" tag.
It looks like this: .
It is also a "void" tag.
It stands for "break"--
and it's a tag--
and you put this after any lines that you want to appear on multiple lines.
Let's play around with this in the browser a little bit.
Here we are in the browser--let's enter some text.
We've got this text that's really too long for one line,
and when we render this, it appears as one line.
Let's put a little line break here.
When I render this,
it still appears as one line.
If we want to render multiple lines,
we can enter the tag, like here--no problem.
And now we have a line break, and we can even enter
multiple tags if we want multiple line breaks.
Okay. There we go.
Two line breaks--or two equals two line breaks,
Cool, huh?
Another way of doing line breaks
is to use the tag.
This stands for "paragraph".
This is not a tag.
So the tag has content and it looks like this.
So because it's not a tag,
it has a closing tag
and we have an opening tag.
So you've got: opening , content, closing .
And this will render as one paragraph.
Let's check this out on the browser really quick.
Okay--so we've got these two lines; let's take a different approach.
I'm going to start this line with a paragraph tag
and we'll render this.
Aha! Now we've got a line break here in our text.
Now the font got bigger and that's kind of a side effect of our HTML tool.
There must be some sort of style set on "p"--that doesn't normally happen.
I'm going to wrap the bottom line with the paragraph as well.
Okay. There we go--now we've got two lines--
the same kind of basic idea as we had before.
Now, we'll talk about why there's this extra space in here,
even though there's no space between this text up here.
We'll come to that in a minute--but first,
quiz time.
Take this text, here: "Hello everyone! We're using two lines now!"
and enter the HTML to draw that,
as it's formatted here--with two lines--and I want you to use the tag.